this started and my friend mark Lebrun
who lives in California here's a
computer scientist he likes to consider
unusual ways of doing arithmetic and he
came up with this idea you know that in
school children have a lot of trouble
when they learn arithmetic all this
there's all this trouble with the
Carrey's
it's very complicated so he said let's
let's make it simple for the kiddies
we're not gonna have any caries we're
gonna abolish all caries we're gonna
change the rules of it now when you add
two digits to numbers like 7 & 8 the
result is not 15 anymore on the moon
it's 8 you pick the bigger of the two
numbers
so 1 plus 1 is 1 sure 1 plus 2 is 2 when
you multiply you pick the smaller so 1
times 2 is 1 and that's it those are the
rules
that's lunar arithmetic so 3 times 8 is
3 3 times 8 is 3 3 plus 8 is 8 you take
the bigger as the two actually
maybe they didn't maybe they will let's
do some realistic let's do an addition
for example supposing we wanted to add
say 58 and 19 what you do is you say 8
plus 9 is no remember you take the
bigger of the two and there are no
carries a plus 9 is no 1 plus 5 is 5 you
take the bigger the - bigger of 1 & 5 is
5 the biggest of 9 + 8 is 9 so 58 plus
19 is equal to 59
that's lunar addition what about
multiplication suppose we want to
multiply say 17 by 24 remember digit by
digit so four sevens are four very good
you pick the smaller
all ones are one and now two sevens two
sevens are two two ones are one and now
we add them up one one plus two is two
you pick the bigger of the two and you
bring down the four so 17 times 24 is
equal to 124 so now you can do a lot of
arithmetic in lunar arithmetic and you
can produce a lot an interesting number
sequences 35 and a half minutes of PLSS
time expanded now what are the squares
what's 1 times 1 is 1 2 times 2 is equal
to pick the smaller it's 2 3 times 3 3
squared is 3 6 squared is 6 7 squared is
7 8 squared is 8 9 squared is 9 what
about 10 squared 10 times 10 we have to
do it zero times zero you pick the
smaller 0 times 1 is 0 1 times 0 is 0 1
times minus 1 you add them up 1 0 plus 0
pick the bigger is it and we get a
hundred just like back on earth but what
about 11 squared well we have to do it 1
1 times 1 1 we get 1 1 1 1 add them up 1
1 plus one is one
what so 11 squared is 1 1 1 111 12
squared 2 times 2 is is 2 2 times 1 is 1
1 times 2 is 1 1 times 1 is 1 always
pick the smaller and we add them up 1 1
plus 1 is 1 2 is 2 so 12 squared is 112
and so on 19 squared is 9 and so on so
that's the sequence of lunar squares
yes we love you don't here we'd like you
to aim it a little bit more to the right
or if you are interested in the formal
details this is an associative
commutative distributive law so it works
we don't have subtraction we don't have
division but apart from that we can do
anything what I would like to tell you
about next are the lunar primes what are
the prime numbers on the moon you're
really gonna like this and I need more
paper what are the lunar probes well
what is a prime first of all we have to
decide what it means for a number to be
a prime now you remember back on earth 7
was a prime because you couldn't write 7
as 2 times 3 or anything except 1 times
7 if the only way to factorize it is as
1 times itself and it's a prime number
on the moon is 7 a prime on the moon
well notice 7 is equal to 8 times 7 it
because 8 times 7 you pick the smaller
of the two which is 7 so 7 is 8 times 7
so 7 is not a prime because it has a
factorization but really before we get
down to the details of this we have to
decide what precisely it means to be a
prime so formally and numbers of prime
if the only factorization is 1 times
itself what does one mean on the moon we
have to say what is 1 if I put it in
quotes on moon well what is 1 1 has the
property that if you multiply anything
by 1 you get what you started with 1
times 3 is 3 1 times 111 is 111 right on
the moon that's not true 1 times 3 on
the moon is not 3 it's 1 1 times I well
one time so 111 happens to be 111 by
accident that well 1 on the moon 1 times
anything is basically all ones and zeros
1 times 30
is ten because you go through a digit by
digit and pick the smaller so one on the
moon is not one what is one on the moon
would you care to make a guess
what's the number is that I haven't
thought about it at nine it's not very
good fantastic brilliant because when
you multiply something by nine it just
copies what it sees nine times seven two
seven nine times one is one
just copies what it sees so on the moon
nine is the one so on the moon a prime
number has the property that the only
way you can factorize it is nine times
itself so seven is obviously not a prime
because seven is equal to 8 times 7 what
about 8 8 is not a prime because an 8 is
equal to 8 times 8 so start a prime it
has a factorization in which one of the
fact neither factor is 9 any number if
for it to be a prime the biggest digit
has to be a 9 so 25 is not a prime
because we could multiply it by 5 and
get what we started with so we thought I
have a 9 in the number so 19 is the
smallest we must have a 9
there's no way to build 19 except what
19 times 9 right you can't factor is
because it's got a 9 in it so if you
know if it was 18 we can multiply 18 by
an 8 and get 18 we'd have a
factorization so you can always multiply
by the biggest digit and get what you
started with so the big biggest digit
had better be 9 these Prime's are going
to be rare than yes but not that all
that rare so yeah how rare are they well
let's look at the prime numbers so what
about 9 itself so back on earth we don't
say 1 as a prime because it's we
wouldn't have unique factorization 2 is
the smallest prime but on the moon just
as one isn't a prime on on earth 9 isn't
a prime but apart from that
we get 19 so the primes the lunar primes
1929 39 49 59 69 79 89 90 is a prime 91
as long as there's a nine and there's no
obvious way to factorize it you have to
check that 90 is a prime we can't get 90
by multiplying two numbers you have to
check it but it's true it's easy to
check 99 we get 109 yes that's a prime
but 119 is not because as we saw a
moment ago 19 times 19 yes
119 so 1 1 9 is not a prime but roughly
speaking most members that have a 9 in
them the primes so those are the lunar
primes if we were to go to the oais and
we're in the search window we type lunar
primes
we used to call them dismal primes
because teaching of arithmetic in
schools were so dismal it's a dismal
definition I think we like lunar primes
much better so well I can show you the
graph or two graphs one of the first 200
terms technically it's called a pimp lot
because we draw little pins you don't
see the pins there because they're quite
dense then you get a scatterplot justice
plane graph of however many terms we
have and it looks like we're getting
about what is it two thousand five
hundred terms there's one more thing I
would like to show you I'd like to prove
that they're infinitely many primes
you remember infinitely many lunar
primes
first of all our prove that 109 is
Breyer and the proof of that is suppose
it wasn't it would have to be the
product of two two-digit numbers they
would have to be two digit numbers
because of the rules so it would have to
be a B times C D but we've got to get a
one at the beginning so one of a and C
remember how it works the table as the
multiplication the tableau you get one
at the beginning either a or C has
one-and-two get a nine at the end both B
and D have to be nines that's the other
only possibility because when we do the
multiplication 9 times 9 is 9 9 times 1
well that's that's 1 pick the smaller of
the two okay now we do the C C times 9
is well it's C whatever C is multiplying
it by and 9 doesn't change it and C
times 1 well C can't be 0 so it's gonna
be 1
now we add them up and we get 1 1 plus C
I don't know what it is it's the bigger
of 1 and C well it's gonna be C it could
be 1 anyway what we get is the number 1
c9 but C can't be 0 because if C was 0
we wouldn't get the 1 in front so this
can't happen this is a contradiction if
C was equal to 0 we wouldn't get the 1
in front
we cannot factorize 109 as a product of
two primes and then likewise 1 0 0 0 0 9
is prime by the same argument there are
infinitely many Prime's yeah no matter
how many you can put as many zeros as
many zeros as you want and you get a
prime nice proof yeah yeah nice no Luna
Prime's coming down the ladder now are
the ones that the mathematicians like
these are the primes or numbers that are
related to primes and they are they are
elevated above the ordinary numbers 0 1
5 27 one nine four one eight six five
and so on